hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in problema one of fear and trembling
Abraham is going to make a vital
distinction between Abraham understood
as the father of faith in this solitary
figure and the tragic hero now
one might be tempted to read this as a
opposition between Athens and Jerusalem
philosophy and faith or Greek culture
and you know Hebrew literature and
culture and that would be completely
wrong why would that be wrong it's not a
clash between Christianity and paganism
because one of the figures who he's
going to discuss as a tragic hero is
somebody right out of the Old Testament
one of the judges Jeptha know the fault
line here runs in a different direction
and before we go on let me mention that
the three heroes that he's talking about
in this section are taken from Greek
Roman and Hebrew literature and history
right
Agamemnon Jeptha and Brutus why pick
those three you might say that
Kierkegaard is covering all of the bases
of classic antiquity the things that
flowed most steadily not exclusively but
but had the greatest impact upon the
development of Western thought so by
addressing them he is like I said
covering his bases he also mentions
Shakespeare showing us that somebody
who's more contemporary is dealing with
tragic heroes and he says why didn't
Shakespeare have any characters like
Abraham in them later on he's also going
to discuss Socrates and how Socrates
functions as a sort of tragic hero less
in action and more in the realm of
thought but of course sacrificing his
own life for philosophy so how are the
tragic heroes
different from somebody like Abraham
this is connected with this notion of
teleological suspension of the ethical
and it's very useful for us to think in
terms of these stages or perspectives
that Kierkegaard sets out in relation to
each other the aesthetic is not going to
be discussed very much here that is the
realm of particular individuals and they
aren't recognising the universal and the
way that the ethical is instead they're
living their lives and maybe making
money enjoying themselves indulging
themselves in certain things pursuing
certain Telos tell you know tell a ends
goals purposes but those that are
germane to themselves and when we find
something as we say bigger than
ourselves that we belong to that helps
place things into context for us whether
that be something intellectual whether
that be something involved in action
whether that be a cause we find
ourselves in the realm of what
Kierkegaard is calling the ethical
there's something Universal that we
recognize and Abraham has this for
Abraham as Kierkegaard points out the
ethical would be his family and indeed
the promise that God is made of many
nations being blessed through him but
it's primarily the small community that
is his family as a set of individuals in
relation to each other he's supposed to
love them that is part of the ethical
for for him now why would we bring up
tragic heroes it's possible to
distinguish levels within the ethical so
it's not just a matter of the religious
versus the ethical versus the aesthetic
there are higher and lower we might say
levels each with their own Telos their
own purpose their own goal that can be
recognized within the ethical and some
of our moral developments and a lot of
our moral
conflicts in fact depend upon this so he
says the tragic hero is still within the
ethical he allows an expression of the
ethical to have its Telos in a higher
expression of the ethical that's a very
important point there and the reason why
Kierkegaard actually brings up these
three guys Agamemnon Jephthah and Brutus
is because each one of them does an act
similar in description to what Abraham
is contemplating doing with Isaac namely
sacrifices or kills their own child why
would somebody kill their child we might
think of all sorts of criminal reasons
that a person might might kill their
child for say you know think about the
case of Medea in antiquity where she
essentially is killing her children to
spite her husband who is cheating on her
and this is looked at as a horrible act
by everybody in antiquity and the only
debate about is how culpable is she in
doing this and how much blame does Jason
bear but it's understood as a violation
of the ethical could there be situations
in which one actually does need to
sacrifice one's child and God says yes
there can be a higher expression of the
ethical he says the tragic hero scales
down the ethical relation between father
and son or daughter and father to a
feeling that has its dialectic in its
relation to the idea of moral conduct
what is that idea of moral conduct this
is something that is needed for the
larger community and in the case of
Agamemnon it has to do with the ship's
being able to sail to Troy there's this
entire fabric of Greek society that is
dependent upon the sacrifice of this
unfortunate person Jeptha he makes a
rash vow to God in order to win victory
for the people of Israel against their
oppressors then he will sacrifice the
first thing that comes
to meet him when he gets home turns out
that it's his daughter Brutus has a son
who doesn't do what he's supposed to do
and rather does the opposite and has to
be executed by his own father who
doesn't and these are viewed as a higher
expression of the ethical there is still
some Telos some point within it and it
has to do with the good of the community
so the tragic hero is indeed somebody
who is in some sense doing the right
thing and and notice what he says about
this when in the crucial moment
Agamemnon Jephthah
and Brutus heroically have overcome the
agony heroically have lost the beloved
they love their children but they they
recognize that they have to kill them
they have only to complete the task
externally there will never be a noble
soul in the world without tears of
compassion for their agony of admiration
for their deed he says what they don't
do is what Abraham does what does
Abraham do this is part of it
he says if in the crucial moment these
three men were to append to the heroic
courage with which they bore the agony
the little phrase but it will not happen
anyway who then would understand them if
they went on to explain this we believed
by virtue of the absurd who would
understand them any better yet that is
what Abraham is according to Kierkegaard
doing Abraham has faith in God that
somehow by virtue of the absurd this is
all going to work out that anything is
possible for God and he believes that
God is in fact demanding the sacrifice
of his child not for a community but for
some thing beyond the ethical so in the
case of the the tragic hero
the person who sacrifices for the good
of their community what they do is
understandable it moves within the realm
of what Kierkegaard calls the you
reversal any one of us we don't want to
step into their place but we could if we
actually possess the courage and the
moral fiber that they have we could do
that and it would make sense
likewise it could be Socrates allowing
the city of Athens to execute him and
choosing not to flee his prison cell
when the guards have been bribed so that
he can take a stand for the practice of
philosophy and the pursuit of wisdom
again there's some sort of universal
human value there and we might think of
countless tragic heroes in our own time
doing similar things recognizing that
they may in fact fail but taking on
those challenges anyway in ways that we
can understand recognize replicates
perhaps so that's the realm of the
tragic hero that's the realm of the
ethical Abraham goes beyond that he is
involved in what Kierkegaard points to
is a higher Telos what is the higher
tellest in this case he tells us in the
text that it is fulfilling the will of
God now some people might view the will
of God as something that is just within
the realm of the ethical and quite often
within not just paganism but within both
Judaism and Christianity that's how it's
understood Kierkegaard will actually say
that a church is really no different
than a state in this respect but there
will be some individuals and he uses
Abraham he also talks about Mary and he
talks about Jesus and His disciples for
whom there is a higher call a higher
call that introduces a greater Telos
that has to be answered to and which
does not provide you with a
justification that other people will be
able to understand because there is the
absurd in
auld there so he says Abraham situation
is a case in which he transgresses the
ethical altogether and had a higher
Telos outside of it he goes on and he
says that why does Abraham do it for
God's sake and the two are wholly
identical for his own sake he does it
for God's sake
because God demands this proof of his
faith he does it for his own sake so he
can prove it and that is as much
explanation as we're really going to get
so what else do we find here gagarin
will talk about he brings this this
catch phrase up over and over again the
anxiety to distress the paradox that is
something within the realm of the
religious the tragic hero may endure
some agony but they can say it is for
the best of the community it is
fulfilling the Telos then I recognize
the higher one they sacrificed the lower
to the higher Abraham goes beyond that
places himself in in an absolute
relation to the absolute as an
individual not mediated through the
universal as the tragic hero does so
this is a vital distinction that
Kierkegaard is making here in problema
one of fear and trembling
you